اهلا وسهلا انا غاطس بام سلم جاي اتكلم
معنا الاغنيه اليمنيه وعندي ثلاثه اسئله
في البدايه احب اسالهم ممكن تجاوبوا برفع
عدناتكم تسمعوا الاغنيه اليمنيه
حلو السؤال الثاني تحبوها
يا سلام السؤال الثالث هل
كانت الاغنيه اليمنيه ما تعجبكمش
تحاولوا تجنبوها بعدين رجعتوا تحبوها
انا منكم
انا ما كنت تسمع الاغنيه اليمنيه ابدا
حكايتي بدات من عمر مبكر جدا وانا صغير
عند
ولدت في غرفه ابوي وامي كان عندهم صوره
الصوره هذه اذا كانت صوره ابي ولا امي ولا
ام مع بعض ولا صور جدي كانت صوره عبد
الكريم عبد القادر
يا اما منو هذا قالت لي والله هذا الفنان
ابوك يحبه وانا ولدت على جو موسيقي وابي
دائما كان يسمع الاغنيه هذه
الفنان هذا
كبرت مع الوقت
وكانت تحصل مشاكل بيني وبين اخواني الصغار
على موضوع الريموت حق التلفزيون واصل
واحنا مشاكل اللي هو
الترفيه الوحيده اللي متوفره عندنا انه
ضروريه
هذه كل واحد
يتفرج مسلسل اطفال انا كنت تشتي تتفرج
مسلسل الاغاني اخواني كانوا يتفرجوا
مسلسلات الاطفال
فاتفقنا الحل انه اتفرج عشر اغاني مقابل
حركه كرتون واحده لهم الاخ الكبير يعني
مشى الموضوع معي كبرت بالثانويات اسمع
الاغاني الانجليزيه
في الجامعه حبيت جدا الموسيقى الغربيه
بشكل ما تخيلوا عجبتنا جدا كنت منذهل جدا
بحجم التنوع التنوع الموسيقي اللي موجود
عندهم الى غايه 2015 وكل واحد مننا معه
قصه في 2015 انا معي قصه في الاغاني انه
ما فيش انترنت ما فيش اي حاجه وكان اشتي
السماعه اغاني صديقي جاب لي فلاش تسمع
اغاني يمنيه
قلت لها حاول تقلبها يعني الطريق الوحيد
اللي اسمع فيه اغاني يمنيه وابو بكر سالم
يا سامر يا نجمي يا سامر صوتي سامر فوق
المصلى
سامر فوق المصل انا قلت الله ايش هذا
اغنيه في ثمان دقائق في عشر دقائق ايش
الجمال اللي فيها هذا
شفتها عباره عن وثيقه تاريخيه
يعني اذا شفته في مشاكل من قبل المتحدثين
في موضوع التوفيق عندنا توفيق في الاغاني
يعني لو تسال تقول له ايش كانوا يلبسوا
ذيك الايام يقول لك
خضاري من العدين بكر مشدته بيضاء وما اشقر
وخبر هذا اللبس
يتناقش موضع سياسي قال لك هجرتني والغلب
غير راضي او سابقون كل الشباب عساكر
الحلال موسيقى تاريخيه معنا
يا مونيه اللي تتكلم عليها
الناس حاولوا ينسبوها شعبيه يقول لك والله
هذه شعبي لما يشيلوها في اماكن
يقولوا
ميدان بالراحه للمشكله هذي الله قصر
الروضه دخلها في الاغنيه الحسيني دخلها
الاغنيه يحلوها وقولوا حقنا هذا حقنا هذا
تراثنا احنا وثقنا على مستوى الكلمه كلمه
احوام مهمه انت يحوم لا تفكر فتندم كلنا
في الهوادم كلنا اولاد ادم
في الموضوع يعني يمكن هذه الدلاله حق اسمي
يعني المهم
ايش احوال لقت فيه وكاتب اسمه محمد عبد
الغانم كتب من عدن
كتبت اعظم كتاب في الاغنيه الصنعانيه
قال احوم هو اللون
الداكن من الاخضر والاحمر كان في اناث
تتصف فيه فكان يسموها احوام فين اجت
الكلمه هذه اول ذكر الكلمه وثقناها في
اغنيه اسمها خلي صقير الترايب قال السحر
في احوامه
ايش الجمال ده من 500 سنه
يحيى بن عمر اليافعي واحد من كبار الناس
اللي كتبت في الاغنيه
كتب اغاني
اه شفت شي في طريقك وعجبك شله بنفس اللحن
بنفس الكلمه من 500 سنه
هذا هو حقا التراث
بس نوصل لمرحله
انه انا اجي في يوم من الايام اقول اشتي
ادور
اشتي استخدم تقنيه من التقنيات الحديثه
اللي انتشرت مؤخرا حق
الذكاء الاصطناعي اللي انتشر كلنا ونعرفه
دوخ الدنيا وتجاوب لك على اسئله ومش عارف
ايش
فلقيت ايش المشكله اكتب له الاغنيه
اليمنيه
كانت اجابته
اه حسين هذه اجابته كانت ليش راح
هذي جارته
قال سالته بالعربي
سالته بالانجليزي قال انه الدبكه من اهم
انواع الرقصات اليمنيه
وانه رابح صقر اهم فنان يمني
المشكله مش مشكلته حقيقه
المشكله مش مشكلته المشكله
رغم ان الناس هنا معكم اليونسكو
اليونسكو كلها تقولوا انه اقدم اغنيه
صنعانيه في القرن الرابع عشر
معه كتاب
الموسيقى العربيه او تاريخ الموسيقى
العربيه حتى القرن الرابع عشر قال حتى
اليوم يقولوا عرب الحجاز ان الموسيقى
العربيه الافضل والحقيقيه تاتي من اليمن
في حين ان المنشدين الحضرميين يعتبرون
دائما فنانين متفوقين
للحجاز كانوا يقولوا علينا في القرن
الرابع عشر
بس احنا قررنا نعمل
مساهمه او يعني استشعار مسؤوليه مسؤوليه
تجاه الفن او الغناء اليمني من اعمال
المشاركه او مساهمه ونعمل موسوعه الغناء
اليمني اخذنا سبعه مجلدات
قلنا تجريبي اطلقنا فيه هذا الموقع
بدل ما الواحد دحين يقول والله اشتهي
كلمات الاغنيه الفلانيه مش عارفين مين
كتبها شفناها مثلا في التلفزيون شفنا يمني
او مش عارف ايش لا ندخل الموقع نكتب الاسم
اغنيه في البحث
بنلاقي كاتب الكلمات الملحن اللي غنوها
بكل بساطه
هاي هذه مسؤوليه نتجاه الاغنيه اليمنيه في
ناس يعملوا مسؤوليتهم ذي الفنانين الجدد
اللي الان طلعوا على الساحه ويعملوا تجديد
في الاغنيه اليمنيه يحاولوا يطوروا فيها
زي ما كانت زمان عدن عدن كانت هي المكان
اللي تطور فيه الاغنيه اليمنيه هي اللي
تحفظ فيه الاغنيه اليمنيه
بعد ما تم تهجير او منع الغناء في صنعها
في الثلاثينات الاربعينات معظم المغنيين
الصنعانيين يقولوا لحقوا عدن
عشان كذلك قال لا مادام سماحه الاغنيه هذه
اشتي اعمل حق اللون
في عدن واحد اسمه علي ابو بكر بشرحيب
يسموه الشيخ الان ومن اكثر الناس اللي
يردد اسمها في حفظ التراث هذا الرجال كان
دلال في المعلم ما عندوش اي حاجه غير انه
دلال
في الجلسه سماع المغنيين الصنعانيين قال
الله ايش الجمال هذا وفعلا الاغنيه
الصنعانيه فيها جزاله في الكلمه يتصاحه في
عمق
قال الله ايش هذا كيف كيف محفوظه فين
الاسطوانات حقكم
مش محفوظه الرجال ايش عمل
شعارا بالمسؤوليه قال لك انا بروح اتعلم
القنب حقنا العوده القديمه تعلم القنبوس
راح الاستوديوهات اللي موجوده في عدن من
عام 37 الى 39 في سنتين حفظ معظم الموروث
اللي جاي كان نقول شفوي الاكثر من 500 سنه
هذا الاسطوانات
رجعت لصنعه حتى الحارثي يقول انه كانت
تسرب له اسطوانات بحيث من اكبر الفنانين
الصنعانيين في هذه الفكره انه كانت
من عدم وجالس اسمعها
هذا الدور عدن عدن كان معها جمعيه
وندوات ثقافيه وكانت تصدر منها ابحاث
حرفيا كان في جمعيات لكل حاجه او كل انواع
الموسيقى حتى في كان
جمعيه اسماء جمعيه انصار بيتهوفن
انتم متخيلين
الزخم اللي كان موجود
اخيرا اشتي اقول حاجه واحده يعني او سؤال
اخير زي ما بدات الموضوع باسئله سؤال اخير
بس الجواب ممكن تحتفظوه فيه او تفكروا فيه
هل
تحسوا بذات الفخر تجاه هذا الاغنيه او
الفن اللي وثق كثير من حياتنا كثير من
تراثنا
ومحتاجين احنا كلنا مش لا انا ولا الفريق
اللي معانا او اصحاب اللي قررنا نعمل هذا
الفكره المشروع او الناس اللي حاولوا في
السوشيال ميديا ينشروه اغاني يمنيه
ويقولوا هذا حقنا واسمعه حقنا ومش عارف
ايش درجه انه في واحد اردني دخلني يقول له
يقول لي ايش الفن العظيم هذا حقكم واحد
اردني ما اعرفوش يعني
الفن العظيم هذا اللي معاكم تكلمنا على
الصحن السهراني يكلمنا على المخادر يقول
لي ايش معنى مخدره
واحد
فهي هذه مسؤوليتنا ومسؤوليتنا جميعا ان
شاء الله
كلنا نكون قد المسؤوليه هذه ونحفظ الفن
هذا وشكرا جزيلا
[تصفيق]